(suspenseful atmospheric music)
- I had two goals setting
out on this expedition.
One was to be the first person
to ride the entire length
of the Ho Chi Minh Trail.
The second was a personal goal
and that was to find the place
where my dad's plane went down in 1972.
Blood Road is sort of a slang name
for the Ho Chi Minh Trail.
And the Ho Chi Minh Trail was the supply route
used during the Vietnam War
for the North Vietnamese to supply arms
and troops towards the south.
The whole route was about
1,200 miles from top to bottom.
It's the longest ride I've ever done,
completely unknown territory.
(poignant music)
My dad served in the Vietnam War
and he was shot down in 1972.
I was just three years old when he died,
and so I don't have any of my
own personal memories of him.
I was looking for a
way to get to know him,
a man that I never knew,
and physically going to the place
and connecting by bicycle was really
the only way I knew how.
The train was a total mixed bag
from pavement in the cities
to using machete.
Plenty of times we had to put our bikes
on the shoulders, and carry
'em up and over a mountain,
but I will say the physical
part of the journey
wasn't the most challenging part
of the journey for me.
For me, it really was
opening up emotionally
and being vulnerable.
There's a huge trench as far as I can see,
just down where the plane slid.
It was the first time in my life
that I felt my dad's presence,
I felt close to him
and I felt like he was there.
And the first time in my life
I felt like I could stop chasing something
and I could just sit,
and be in that moment.
As a professional athlete,
I'm trained to be strong and independent
and show no weakness.
It took me by surprise
that it impacted me that much.